hey 42 here do you ever get the feeling
that people are talking about you behind
your back well that's because they are
pretty much every shop restaurant and
bar in the world uses a system of secret
codes to communicate between staff
members without alerting customers to an
alarming situation or to simply insult
customers without them realizing
Transport for London often called TfL
have been using secret codes in
abundance for a long time as one can
imagine being in charge of all the
public transport in the city of London
means there are literally hundreds of
issues to deal with on a daily basis
from someone ejecting their dinner on
the bus or something more serious such
as terrorism TfL have a code for it as
you would expect from a public transport
operator most of their codes are used to
request cleanups our various bodily
fluids ejected from commuters to start
from the beginning
code one means blood co2 is your een
and/or faeces code free is vomit code
four is a general spillage which is
probably the least disgusting thing on
this list code five is broken glass code
six is litter and finally a code seven
is anything that doesn't fit into the
previous categories you know for those
odd times when something comes out of
your body and you think to yourself what
the hell is that
but TfL have a far more serious secret
code by the name of Inspector Sons which
is used to alert the police and overall
priorities to either a fire or a bomb
scare without causing the general public
to panic this is a recording of the
chilling announcement played in an
underground tube station
inspector sound inspector fund please
report to control if the issue is not
investigated within three minutes of the
warning sounding then the station will
be automatically evacuated the message
was played on repeat across all London
Tube stations during the 7/7 London
bombings the world's largest retailer
Walmart has a whole array of staff codes
that are blasted over the tano's in
various situations from code blue which
is a bomb threat to code green which
means there's a hostage situation but
Walmart is best known for creating a
code that is now widely used by
thousands of establishments across
America code atom in 1981 a six-year-old
boy named Adam was abducted in Sears
department store in Florida public
service announcements were made across
the store that Adam was lost after a
long search he was found decapitated in
memory of Adam Walmart introduced code
Adam to signal a lost child in one of
their stores but it's more than just a
code there's a step-by-step system that
all employees are trained to follow if a
child is reported missing code Adam is
announced across the store and all
exterior exits are immediately locked a
description of the missing child is
paged to all store employees and they
will begin a search if the child is not
found within 10 minutes then law
enforcement is called the doors are only
unlocked once the child is found on
harmed all law-enforcement takes over
the case the system works so well that
in 2003 Congress passed legislation that
made it a legal requirement for all
federal buildings in the u.s. to
implement code Adam another codes that
signifies imminent danger is time check
it's used commonly in department stores
in the UK specifically John Lewis and
IKEA it means there's an ongoing bomb
scare if employees here time check
announced they must immediately stop
what they're doing and search for
suspicious packages or unattended box
emergency codes are even used away from
dryland even when there are no icebergs
about there's still a lot that can go
wrong on a cruise ship and with the
average age of cruise ship passengers
being over 50 they are basically
floating nursing homes so it's no
surprise then that over 200 people died
on cruise ships each year to accommodate
this all cruise ships actually have
morgues onboard it's a legal requirement
but what happens when someone does pass
away do the crewmembers hastily wrap
them up in bed linen and push them to
the morgue on the drinks trolley no they
have a secret code of course operation
rising star is broadcast across the
vessel when a passenger has passed away
and if you were to hear operation bright
star that signals a medical emergency
emergency codes are also heavily
utilized up in the air airlines use
secret codes to communicate more
frequently than most other companies
you'll often see cabin crew Ottoman
gibberish into walkie-talkies one of the
most serious is a code 7,500 which means
the plane has been hijacked there are
other codes such as 7600 which indicate
a radio failure but there's also a code
7700 which means a general emergency so
it could be anything from the toilet
being blocked to a couple of
holidaymakers panicking because they
left their son Kevin at the airport but
rather strangely there's also code Bravo
which is the complete opposite of all
the other codes we've discussed because
it's intended to intentionally cause
panic a flight attendant will repeatedly
shout code Bravo loudly if they want
passengers to panic in order to distract
their attention away from something more
serious going on on the plane that needs
to be dealt with without interference
from the public of course secret codes
can also be used to make fun of people
without them having any idea what you're
going on about IT departments across the
world share a common code that's often
used when assisting muggles with their
never-ending
peuta problems the code is Petka and it
stands for problem exists between
keyboard and chair in other words the
computer isn't broken
you are IT professionals have been known
to write this code on incident report
forms the world over Oh
and lastly bartenders across the world
also have a large numerical code system
such as a code 300 which means a guest
needs assistance or 86 meaning the
product is out of stock if you're in a
bar and the bartender says 690 it means
that a hot girl just walked it so there
you go you now know all the secret codes
that are intended to stop you from
panicking in an emergency so in the
future you can now be suitably panicked
you're welcome thanks for watching but
in reality how real is the American
president's power how much power do they
really possess but how far does the
influence of drugs stretch throughout
the development of mankind